[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Heinz
Wolf und Christian Siebers hallo und
guten Abend ihnen allen das war heute
eine hochemotionale Debatte im Parlament
was ja nicht schlecht ist was zeigt es
geht um was und es geht uns alle an die
Nachricht danach lautet das sogenannte
Bürgergeld also der Nachfolger des
hartz-iv-systems hat den Bundestag
passiert damit und das zeigt sich
bereits in der Debatte ist die Sache
aber nicht gelaufen denn auch der
Bundesrat muss zustimmen und da wird es
problematisch denn was für die einen
etwa den Bundesarbeitsminister die
größte
sozialstaatsreform seit 20 Jahren ist
steckt für die anderen etwa die CDU
voller inhaltlicher Webfehler Frank
Buchwald hat die Einzelheiten
auf diesen Tag hat Hubertus Heil lange
gewartet das alte Trauma der SPD Hartz
IV der Minister will es endlich
loswerden heute im Bundestag das
Bürgergeld es gehe um Chancen sagt heil
und um Schicksale hatte Bankkaufmann
gelernt hat gearbeitet der ist dann
erkrankt hat seine Arbeit verloren es
war eine langjährige Erkrankung es ging
irgendwann gesundheitlich besser aber
jahrelang sich die fingerbund
geschrieben nach langen Jahren der
Arbeitslosigkeit ohne eine Chance auf
Arbeit wieder zu bekommen weil er zu
lange draußen war der Minister berichtet
von eigenen Begegnungen Heil gestern zu
Besuch bei einer Maschinenbau Zulieferer
in Berlin nicht zufällig sind viele
Journalisten dabei das Unternehmen gibt
Menschen eine Chance die lange
arbeitslos waren positiv bei Spiele Heil
hört zu und freut sich naja man hat auch
ein anderes Auftreten man nicht glaube
dass das Selbstbewusstsein das wird
anders
solche Geschichten kennt natürlich auch
die Union vieles hat sie in ihrer
Regierungszeit mitgetragen jetzt in der
Opposition kritisiert sie das Bürgergeld
es schaffe zu wenig Anreiz arbeiten zu
gehen bis heute verweigern sie jede
sachliche Debatte über die
grundsätzlichen wetfehler ihres Gesetzes
glauben Sie im Ernst die Arroganz der
Mehrheit im Bundestag erhöht die Chancen
auf eine Mehrheit im Bundesrat keine
leere Drohung im Bundesrat kann die
Union das Gesetz ausbremsen sie will
zwar das Arbeitslosengeld erhöhen schon
Vermögen Sanktionen und Regelsätze aber
neu aushandeln die FDP findet das
scheinheilig vollends schizophren wird
es wenn sie behaupten durch das Geld
lohne sich Arbeit in Deutschland nicht
mehr das ist erstens in jedem einzelnen
Fall falsch und zweit
ens die eine CDU-Ministerin selber
eingeführt hat genau hier setzt die
Kritik der Linken an gerade weil das
Bürgergeld zu viel der schröderschen
Agenda fortschreibe verdiene es seinen
Namen eigentlich nicht
real ist es eben keine Abkehr von Hartz
IV das System bleibt erhalten in
der Subst fünf meine Damen und Herren
wie die Sache heißt dürfte den
Beschäftigten des Berliner Start-ups
gleich sein sie haben ihre zweite Chance
bekommen die Arbeitsagentur übernimmt
befristet einen Teil ihres Lohns soziale
Arbeitsmarkt auch er gehört zum Konzept
des neuen Bürgergeldes
heilsgesetz geht jetzt erstmal in die
Mühlen des parlamentarischen Betriebs
wenn die Unionsländer ist im Bundesrat
blockieren wandert das Bürgergeld in den
Vermittlungsausschuss und das kann
dauern
und dann entscheidet der Bundestag heute
Abend ab 22 Uhr also abseits der
gebannten Aufmerksamkeit des helligten
Tages über einen Fall gewissermaßen in
eigener Sache den wir im Schutze der
Nacht nicht einfach übergehen sollten es
geht um die Frage muss auch die
Bundestagswahl in Berlin wiederholt
werden klar ist am Wahltag im September
letzten Jahres gab es in Berlin
haarsträubende Zustände die mit einer
funktionierenden Demokratie deren
Grundlage ja freie Wahlen sind nicht zu
vereinbaren sind da konnte nicht mehr
gewählt werden obwohl Menschen wählen
wollten da wurde noch gewählt obwohl
längst alle Wahllokale geschlossen sein
sollten es fehlten Stimmzettel und es
gab falsche Stimmzettel die landeswahl
muss wohl komplett wiederholt werden
zumindest hat das Berliner
Verfassungsgericht signalisiert dass es
am kommenden Mittwoch so entscheiden
wird
was aber ist mit der Bundestagswahl die
zeitgleich gefunden hatte Frage Anschlag
unter labernergie in Berlin guten Abend
Check und Allah wie entscheidet denn
oder wie wird denn der Bundestag
womöglich entscheiden ja voraussichtlich
so wie sich die Ampel Mehrheit das im
Wahlprüfungsausschuss überlegt hat die
schlägt nämlich vor dass in gut einem
Drittel der Berliner Wahl der
Betroffenen Berliner Wahlbezirke die
Wahl wiederholt wird und zwar mit erst-
und Zweitstimme damit ist sie deutlich
nachsichtiger als der Bundeswahlleiter
der eine Wahlwiederholung in viel
größerem Umfang für nötig hält ähnlich
sieht das die Union die das ganze
kritisiert und Parteitaktik vermutet sie
sagt die Ampel hätte sich das so zurecht
gerechnet dass es ein größeres Risiko
für die CDU gibt Stimmen bei einer
Wahlwiederholung zu verlieren und man
ist sich hier in Berlin eigentlich
relativ sicher dass der Streit heute mit
der Abstimmung im Bundestag nicht
beigelegt ist sondern dass das Ganze vor
dem Bundesverfassungsgericht landet und
damit ist eines auf jeden Fall nicht
gesichert nämlich eine schnelle
Wahlwiederholung sowie der
Bundeswahlleiter sich das und was würde
denn so eine dann eher begrenzte und
kleine Wahlwiederholung bedeuten für die
Zusammensetzung des Parlaments und der
Mehrheiten dort also sehr wahrscheinlich
ein Stühle rücken es würde
Personalwechsel geben es könnten weniger
Stimmen weniger Sitze für Berlin dabei
rauskommen im Bundestag wenn zum
Beispiel die Wahlbeteiligung geringer
ist als beim letzten Mal die war beim
letzten Mal sehr hoch und für die Linke
könnte das Ganze sehr riskant werden die
ist nämlich nur im Bundestag weil sie
drei Direktmandate errungen hat zwei
davon liegen in betroffenen Wahlbezirken
in denen die Wahl wiederholt werden soll
zwar hat die Linke dort großen Vorsprung
bei den Direktmandaten aber die Welt hat
sich seit der Bundestagswahl extrem
verändert und das bedeutet die
Wählerinnen und Wähler gehen hier unter
ganz anderen Voraussetzungen an die
Wahlurne und deswegen kann sich hier
niemand sicher sein wie das Ganze
ausgehen würde interessante und wichtige
Einordnung shakutaler herzlichen Dank
dafür nach Berlin
so um klar zu machen um was es jetzt
geht müssen wir eine Landkarte dazu
nehmen die macht es dann sehr deutlich
in der Ukraine ist die Region Carson
eine von vier Regionen die Russland
völkerrechtswidrig annektiert hatte und
zum russischen Staatsgebiet erklärt
Teile derselben Region will Russland
jetzt militärisch aufgeben
4.800 Quadratkilometern das hat verteilt
das Verteidigungsministerium in Moskau
mitgeteilt damit würde sich Russland
vollständig auf die Ostseite des Flusses
nepro zurückziehen
die Ukraine reagiert bislang
ungewöhnlich Verhalten auf die
Ankündigung denn es bleiben viele Fragen
aus unmittelbarer Nähe der Frontlinie
berichtet Dara Hassan Sade
ukrainische Soldaten hießen ihre Fahne
ins niorifa 55 km nördlich von herson
man glaube erst an einen russischen
Rückzug aus herson wenn dort die Fahne
der Ukraine wehe sagt präsidentenberater
podoljak heute auch sein Vorgesetzter
Markt
der Feind verteilt keine Geschenke macht
keine Gesten des guten Willens wir haben
das selbst erreicht und wenn man im
Krieg ist muss man sich immer bewusst
sein jeder Schritt erfolgt unter
Widerstand des Feindes es ist immer mit
dem Verlust unserer Helden verbunden
alexandrifka ebenso nördlich von hairson
gelegen die Kleinstadt in der einmal
12.000 Menschen lebten war fast sieben
Monate unter russischer Besatzung die
meisten hier sind Kleinbauern wie volo
du mir nach der Befreiung setzte der
Beschuss der russischen Artillerie ein
meine Frau wurde getroffen
sie war zehn Tage im Koma und dann starb
sie
können sich vorstellen was das für mich
bedeutet
wir fahren weiter nach Süden in das
Umland von herson in das Dorf
ossokoriefka hier ist kein Haus mehr
bewohnbar durch das Dorf verlief die
Front des wurde zum Schlachtfeld die
tostepanovic hat während der Kämpfe sein
Haus nicht verlassen und ukrainischen
Soldaten geholfen ihnen Unterstand
gewährt Granaten schlugen in sein Haus
ich war schwer verletzt aber ich bin
dankbar
ein paar Minuten später und nichts hätte
mich mehr gerettet ich wäre verblutet
eine Ambulanz kam noch rechtzeitig
die Front ist auch heute nur 12 km
entfernt der angekündigte Rückzug der
russischen Armee wirkt sich hier noch
nicht aus
die Menschen fürchten noch immer um ihr
Leben weil die Bombardierung nicht
aufgehört haben
und sie werden weitergehen bis die
russische Armee tatsächlich weg ist
Aufnahmen die auf einen Rückzug der
russischen Armee bei herson hindeuten
die Ukraine zerstörten die Brücken um
Russland zum Rückzug zu zwingen jetzt
behindern kaputte Brücken genau diesen
Rückzug
gehen wir jetzt noch live in die Ukraine
da hallo wir haben es gerade in deinem
Beitrag gehört praktisch alle Brücken
über den libro sind gesprengt der Winter
kommt wie wird denn dieser angekündigte
Rückzug jetzt auf ukrainischer Seite
aufgenommen
ja hier unter den Menschen ist eine
gedämpfte Stimmung man macht keine Witze
es kursieren auch keine Karikaturen im
Internet so wie das damals der Fall war
als das Kriegs russische Kriegsschiff
die Moskwa abgeschossen wurde und
eigentlich sind da die Ukraine auch sehr
ironische witzige Menschen doch ich
denke man traut dem ganzen noch nicht so
und es ist sehr hart das Leben von
vielen Ukrainern im Moment sie haben
keinen Strom die Luftangriffe gehen
weiter auch heute wieder und viele haben
auch keine Heizung und es wird kalt der
Winter kommt und wenn wir uns das ganze
noch kurz aus strategischer Sicht
angucken ist denn dieser Rückzug aus
herson eine entscheidende Niederlage für
Vladimir Putin
also ein Kriegsziel ist jetzt ziemlich
weit in die Ferne gerückt nämlich der
Vormarsch nach Odessa das wird jetzt
fast nicht mehr möglich sein für ihn das
umsetzen zu können und dann kommt noch
hinzu dass wenn Herr Sonn in
ukrainischer Hand ist die amerikanischen
Heimat vielleicht auch die deutschen
Geschosse bis weit in die Krim schießen
können dort Munitionslager treffen
können zudem ist herrson auch bedeutend
für die Grimm was sie
süßwasserversorgung angeht so gesehen
ist er strategisch sehr unter Druck im
Kreml herzlichen Dank darauf für diese
Analyse auch heute Abend wieder live aus
der Ukraine und zum Thema nachher im
heute journal Update die Einschätzung
von Christian Mölling er ist
Forschungsdirektor der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik so
wir bleiben noch einen Moment beim
russischen Präsidenten jetzt bei dir
eins ja Vladimir Putin hatte lange offen
gelassen ob er an dem G20-Gipfel
kommende Woche in Indonesien teilnehmen
wird heute kam nun die Mitteilung er
werde nicht anreisen russland werde dort
von Außenminister lavrov vertreten
anwesend sein werden dagegen
US-Präsident beiden und China Staatschef
Hietzing ping und wie das Weiße Haus und
Washington bekannt gab kommen die beiden
am Rande des Gipfels auch zu ihrem
ersten bilateralen Treffen zusammen
der Bundestag hat heute neben dem
Bürgergeld auch eine Reihe von
Entlastungen beschlossen unter anderem
für Gas- und fernwärmekundinnen und
Kunden die Soforthilfe im Dezember als
Überbrückung bis die gaspreisbremse im
März oder Februar nächsten Jahres kommt
außerdem eine Reform des Wohngeldes es
soll erhöht werden und künftig mehr
Menschen zugute kommen auch das
Kindergeld steigt und es wurden
steuerliche Entlastungen verabschiedet
darunter eine Anhebung des
Grundfreibetrags
und der Bundestag hat eine umstrittene
Regelung zur sogenannten Triage
beschlossen zur Situation wenn aufgrund
einer übertragbaren Krankheit etwa einer
Pandemie nicht ausreichend
intensivmedizinische
Behandlungskapazitäten vorhanden sind
entschieden werden soll in einem solchen
Fall maßgeblich nach der aktuellen und
kurzfristigen
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit eines
Patienten niemand dürfe benachteiligt
werden etwa wegen einer Behinderung oder
wegen des Alters
alle Handybesitzer in Deutschland werden
in den kommenden Tagen mit einer SMS
über das neue katastrophenwarnsystem
sell broadcast informiert das kündigten
die drei Netzbetreiber an die
Warnnachrichten des Systems erreichen
alle Mobiltelefone die in einer
Funkzelle eingebucht sind ohne dass eine
App dafür nötig ist zusätzlich ertönt
ein lautes Tonsignal
bundesweit erstmals getestet werden soll
das Warnsystem dann am 8 Dezember
das Rettungsschiff Ocean Viking mit mehr
als 200 Menschen an Bord darf nach
tagelangem warten vor der italienischen
Küste nun in Frankreich anlegen seit
mehr als zwei Wochen kreuzt das Schiff
der
hilfsorganisations Ultra Rechte
Regierung einen Hafen verweigerte
Frankreich verurteilte das Verhalten
Roms und erwartet das Schiff morgen in
Toulon Deutschland und Frankreich haben
zugesagt einen Teil der geflüchteten
aufzunehmen
die USA sind in vielen Dingen das merkt
bereits jeder Tourist schnell
überraschend fortschrittlich und
merkwürdig rückständig zugleich und so
schaut die Welt auch bei den Wichtigen
Zwischenwahlen weiter gespannt und
gebannt auf teilweise archaische auf
jeden Fall von Bundesstaat zu
Bundesstaat immer neue und komplizierte
Auszählungen die führen dazu dass auch
zwei Tage nach der Wahl nicht klar ist
werden nun die Macht hat im neuen
Repräsentantenhaus und im neuen Senat
aus Washington Claudia Bates
Glückwunsch ich freue mich so für Dich
Joe Biden ruft alle Demokraten an die
gewonnen haben er hat zwar noch keine
Mehrheit im Kongress aber trotzdem gut
lachen denn das Ergebnis der
Zwischenwahlen wird für die Demokraten
wohl das beste eines amtierenden
Präsidenten seit 20 Jahren
das war ein guter Tag für die Demokratie
und ein guter Tag für Amerika unsere
Demokratie wurde in den vergangenen
Jahren herausgefordert aber mit ihren
Stimmen haben die Amerikaner gesprochen
und bewiesen das Demokratie das ist was
uns ausmacht
allerdings sind die Republikaner immer
noch auf dem Weg zu einer möglichen
Mehrheit mindestens in einer
Parlamentskammer und geben sich
schmalepig aber zuversichtlich
ja sagt Kevin McCarthy er werde der neue
republikanische Sprecher des
Repräsentantenhauses im Senat fehlen den
Demokraten wie den Republikanern noch
zwei Sitze für eine Mehrheit im
Repräsentantenhaus ist es ebenfalls
knapp die Republikaner haben einen
leichten Vorsprung bis es Klarheit gibt
könnten noch Tage oder gar Wochen
vergehen mancherorts wird elektronisch
gezählt anderswo von Hand und zum Teil
sind noch nicht mal alle Stimmzettel da
die briefwahlzettel werden noch bis
Samstag angenommen solange der
Poststempel vom Wahltag drauf ist
und nicht nur das manche Wähler müssen
sogar persönlich noch ermittelt und
kontaktiert werden wenn es Zweifel an
der Unterschrift auf dem Umschlag gibt
dann meldet sich ein Wahlhelfer beim
Wähler und bittet um die Bestätigung
dass das seine Unterschrift und sein
Wahlzettel ist
besonders knapp ist das senatsrennen im
schlüsselstaat Georgia der Senator und
Pastor Raphael Warnock und der
ex-football-star und Trump Kandidat
Herschel Walker müssen in die Stichwahl
am Ende könnte dieses eine Rennen über
die Mehrheit im Senat entscheiden
seid ihr bereit für die nächste Runde
die Stichwahl ist am 6 Dezember dann
also wird wohl spätere das
Gesamtergebnis der zwischenwahl
feststehen
und damit nach Deutschland den Tätern
auf die Spur kommen ohne pauschal alle
zu verdächtigen das ist grob gesagt der
Balanceakt den die Justizministerin und
Minister der Bundesländer heute gehen
mussten und zwar ebenso wichtigen Kampf
gegen sexuellen Missbrauch von Kindern
am Ende stand ein knappes Ergebnis für
ein Verfahren das bei einem
Anfangsverdacht die Computerdaten
einzelner Nutzer für einen bestimmten
Zeitraum speichern soll und gegen
allgemeine Vorratsdatenspeicherungen von
IP-Adressen mit denen einzelne Computer
im Netz identifizierbar sind
wie wichtig zusätzlich zu den
gesetzlichen Regelungen eine neue
strukturierte strukturierte
Polizeiarbeit ist das zeigt dort Färber
jetzt am Beispiel NRW
Rechner Handys Sexspielzeuge was hier
lagert steht für schreckliche taten es
sind Beweismittel für den Missbrauch von
Kindern die die Kölner Polizei
sichergestellt hat das ist ein
kinderslip der bei einem Beschuldigten
gefunden wurde sind nur man fragt sie
natürlich wenn jemand der keine Kinder
hat und gerade in so einem Blickfeld
jetzt auffällig geworden ist was macht
er mit der Kinderwäsche
immer neue Beweismittel derzeit
ermitteln Sie in Köln zu einem
missbrauchskomplex mit über 120
Beschuldigten es sind riesige
Datenmengen sie werden Fotos Videos
Chats aus und finden immer mehr die
Belastung stemmen sie im Team wenn einer
was sieht
wo man sagt okay das habe ich aber auch
noch nie gesehen oder wie die hier
miteinander schreiben das ist ja
wirklich die perverse Art und Weise wie
man
Fantasien ausleben möchte am liebsten
dann tauscht man sich aus dann nimmt man
die anderen quasi mit ins Boot und
versucht diese Last so ein bisschen im
Gespräch dann aufzuteilen und dann eben
zu verarbeiten seit 2019 beschäftigt
sich Nordrhein-Westfalens Polizei
systematisch mit missbrauchsermittlungen
lüchte Münster Bergisch Gladbach
Wermelskirchen die Namen das
polizeipersonal dafür hat der
Innenminister verfümfacht und noch mehr
geändert wir haben die Polizei technisch
ganz anders aufgestellt wir haben ein
zentralen Rechner wenn man mal im Bild
bleiben will im Landeskriminalamt und
wir haben so was wie ein virtuelles
Großraumbüro geschaffen es gab es vorher
gar nicht und wenn sie jetzt in Köln zu
Durchsuchungen fahren kommt später noch
ein Datenträger Spürhund hinterher als
Regelfall sie haben spezielle Software
angeschafft verschiedene Programme für
bessere Ergebnisse wir haben gelernt
dass wir als Polizei
viel technikaffiner werden müssen wir
haben es mit Tätern mit Tatverdächtigen
zu tun die uns
da wirklich hohe Hürden setzen um ein
ihr Handy zu kommen um an den Rechner zu
kommen auch da haben wir uns sehr viel
weiterentwickelt manche Verdächtige aber
können nicht ermittelt werden weil die
IP-Adressen fehlen
Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht nicht hat
gerade erst der Europäische Gerichtshof
bestätigt
auf der Justizministerkonferenz fordern
Sie jetzt entschiedeneres vorgehen
wenn diese IP-Adressen nicht gespeichert
werden können und vor allem dann nicht
zugeordnet werden können sind die
Ermittlungen an diesem Punkt schon
beendet und deswegen erwarten wir von
der Bundesregierung vom Bundestag dass
der Spielraum den der EuGH zugelassen
hat dass der auch genutzt wird die
Arbeit bleibt äußerst belastend was sie
motiviert sind die Erfolge sie beenden
den Missbrauch von Kindern immer wieder
aufs Neue
jetzt in der Sendung noch mal du halt
der Energiekonzern RWE hat heute über
seine Geschäftsentwicklung in den ersten
drei Quartalen dieses Jahres informiert
und da ging es auch um die geplante
Gewinnabschöpfung Stefanie berrett wie
ist da der stand ja der Energiekonzern
RWE ist ja bekanntlich einer der ganz
großen Profiteure der Energiekrise und
hat in diesem Jahr vor allem mit
Ökostrom und dem Energiehandel prächtig
verdient auf satte 2,1 Milliarden Euro
verdoppeln konnte der Versorger sein
Gewinn vor Steuern im Vergleich zum
Vorjahr dass die Bundesregierung diese
Gewinne nun abschöpfen will alarmiert
die gesamte Energiebranche RWE warnte
heute nun vor allem die privaten
Unternehmen würden die Kosten für die
Energiewende stemmen müssen dazu sollten
auch Rahmenbedingungen verlässlich
bleiben im Klartext die Daumenschrauben
sollten aus Sicht von RWE nicht zu sehr
angezogen werden dabei hat der Bund
offenbar erste Pläne bereits abgemildert
ursprünglich sollte die Abschöpfung
rückwirkend zum märz gelten nun soll sie
wohl erst ab no übergreifen Einnahmen
von 30 Milliarden Euro erhofft sich der
Bund daraus und will damit die Strom-
und gaspreisbremse finanzieren moralisch
wünschenswert mag eine Gewinnabschöpfung
sein doch das Gesetz istvorhaben ist das
muss man offen zugeben kompliziert und
auch rechtlich anfechtbar noch ein Blick
auf diese beeindruckende Kurve hinter
mir heute Nachmittag schoss der DAX aus
dem Stand nach oben und durchbrach die
Schallmauer von 14.000 Punkten zuvor war
die us-inflationsrate bekannt geworden
sie ist im Oktober überraschend deutlich
von 8,2 auf 7,7% gefallen damit lässt
der Preisdruck in den USA den vierten
Monat in Folge nach die entschlossenen
und kräftigen Zinssenkungen der
US-Notenbank zeigen offenbar ihre
Wirkung Stefanie berrett vielen Dank
vom Bundesverfassungsgericht kommt eine
Entscheidung zu Windenergieanlagen
demnach dürfen die Bundesländer solche
Anlagen in Waldgebieten nicht generell
verbieten in den einzelnen Bundesländern
ist die Nutzung von Waldflächen für die
Windenergie derzeit unterschiedlich
geregelt im konkreten Fall ging es um
eine entsprechende verbotsvorschrift im
Thüringer Waldgesetz die die Richter für
verfassungswidrig und damit nichtig
erklärten
in New York werden zur Stunde weitere
Werke aus der privaten Kunstsammlung von
Microsoft Mitbegründer Paul Allen
versteigert bereits im ersten Tag der
Auktion bei kristys hatten 60
Meisterwerke darunter Gemälde von Sora
sissan oder van Gogh eine Rekordsumme
von umgerechnet gut 1,5 Milliarden Euro
erzielt der Erlös der insgesamt 150
Werke soll so hat es sich der 2018
verstorbene Milliardär allen gewünscht
ausschließlich wohltätigen Zwecken
zugute kommen
der Hans-joachim friedrichspreis ist an
den spiegelreporter Christoph Reuter und
den russischsprachigen Fernsehsender
ostwest TV aus Berlin verliehen worden
für ihre Ukraine Berichterstattung und
mit dem Sonderpreis wurde die
zdf-kindernachrichtensendung Logo geehrt
weil sie die komplizierte Weltlage klar
erkläre nicht selten besser und
unaufgeregter als bei den großen so die
Jury zu sehen ist Logo täglich beim
Kinderkanal Kika und in der ZDF
Mediathek
herzlichen Glückwunsch vielleicht muss
man sich das mit
fußball-nationalspielern auch ein
bisschen so vorstellen wie beim
Nobelpreis man sitzt zu Hause und dann
klingelt das Telefon und ein Anruf
ändert alles
das war auf jeden Fall eine emotionale
Aufgabe für den Bundestrainer 26 mal
zusagen aber auch eben eine ganze Reihe
Absagen jetzt steht der Kader für Katar
am Montag geht es ins Kurztrainingslager
in den Oman exakt heute in einer Woche
dann weiter ins WM-Quartier und am 23
November ist erstes Spiel gegen Japan
Thomas golski
der Ex-Bundestrainer hatte eine
historische Trainingsjacke über
gestreift Modell Helmut Schön um seine
Nachfolgern Glück zu wünschen
nostalgisch angehaucht auch die
Nominierung des Weltmeister Machers von
2014 Mario Götze nach fünf Jahren kehrt
er zurück in die Nationalelf verdienter
Maaßen man sieht sein jedem Spieler ist
als topfit er kann 90 Minuten auch
dreimal die Woche gehen und dann ist es
einfach auch ein genialer Fußballer und
noch ein toller Mensch
nicht dabei dagegen Mats Hummels und das
für viele überraschend auch wenn der in
Topform klaglos jede Rolle akzeptiert
hätte auch die Ersatzbank natürlich auch
vielleicht noch ein bisschen die Zukunft
im Blick haben das war gesagt haben okay
wir haben es für jüngeren Spieler
entschieden nicht gegen mats und wir
haben uns für die Mannschaft entschieden
mit Amel Bella Kocak ein 20-jähriger im
Kreis der Abwehrspieler um Antonio
Rüdiger große Hoffnungen schöpft der
Bundestrainer aus der Form der Bayern
sechs Feldspieler neben Torhüter neuer
sind dabei und zur rechten Zeit in
bester Form 20 Tore in den letzten fünf
Pflichtspielen die Bayern wieder spitze
dank Julian nagelsmann bei Julian schon
ich habe eine WhatsApp geschrieben hat
gesagt ich freue mich echt dass ihr so
gut performt allen voran der 19-Jährige
Jamal musila der magische einer der
Topscorer der Liga auch für den
Bundestrainer inzwischen gesetzt der
zweite Teenager im Team jusufa mukoko 18
wird er am Tag des Eröffnungsspiels eher
einer der jüngsten Profis der Liga der
jüngste Torschütze er würde auch der
jüngste deutsche WM-Spiel wie er noch
ohne Länderspiel auch Niklas Füllkrug
ein Mittelstürmer klassischer Natur wie
in Deutschland lange vermisst hat einer
das Richten kann wenn sonst nichts ging
schließlich war einst auch Horst rubesch
vor der EM 1980 noch ohne Länderspiel
Tor und traf dann im Finale gleich
zweimal zum Titel ein bisschen Nostalgie
eben
ja Vorgänger Jogi Löw hat sich dann
heute noch mit einem Tipp bei Hansi
Flick gemeldet denkt dran was uns 2014
stark gemacht hat wir haben jede Sekunde
daran geglaubt dass wir Weltmeister
werden
bei Maybrit Illner jetzt gleich die
Parteichefs von SPD und FDP unter
anderem Amerikas Egoismus Deutschlands
Dilemma manövriert sich Deutschland beim
Handel ins Abseits und landet am Ende
zwischen allen Stühlen das ist die
interessante Fragestellung und morgen
freut sich an dieser Stelle Marietta auf
sie ich sag bis nächste Woche und um
0.30 meldet sich Wulff schmiese mit dem
heutigen Update wir wünschen Ihnen noch
einen angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend heute Nacht bereitet sich
hier in Süddeutschland wieder Nebel aus
zwischen der Lausitz und dem Niederrhein
ist das klar und über den Norden ziehen
einige dichtere Wolkenfelder und das
ganze bei einem recht kräftigen Wind an
der Nordsee aus südwestlichen Richtungen
die Temperaturen zeigen das übliche
Herbstbild unter den Wolken in der Nähe
des noch warmen Wassers von Ost und
Nordsee bleibt es mild bei 12 bis 10
Grad sonst gehen die Temperaturen auf 9
bis 4 Grad zurück und in Süddeutschland
sinken sie auf +3 bis -1 Grad morgen
liegen die Höchsttemperaturen meist bei
11 bis 16 Grad nur wenn sich der
nebelzell halten kann dann sind es nur
so acht bis zehn Grad und das könnte
morgen zum Beispiel im Donautal oder
auch am Bodensee der Fall sein sonst
gibt es viel Sonnenschein und im Norden
auch einige Wolkenfelder mit
nebelhochnebelt und Sonnenschein haben
wir es auch am Wochenende zu tun das
Hoch hier zieht weiter nach Osten
zusammen mit dem tief über dem Atlantik
bleibt es bei uns in Mitteleuropa und
auch bei uns in Deutschland sehr mild
mit Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 7 und 17
Grad und erst am Montag gibt es im
Südwesten neuen Regen und jetzt schauen
wir noch mal ganz woanders hin nämlich
über den Atlantik in die Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika genauer nach Florida
denn da hat der Tropensturm Nicole
Florida bereits wieder verlassen zieht
jetzt über den Golf von Mexiko und dann
weiter nach Norden so ein Tropensturm
braucht ganz bestimmte Voraussetzungen
und eine dieser Voraussetzungen ist eine
Wassertemperatur von mehr als 26 Grad
die gibt es weltweit noch immer
verbreitet da können also weitere
Tropenstürme sich entwickeln guten Abend